everyone willing to talk about it
publicly but you know we are all kind of
worried off you know anything legal
cases lawsuits etc what I felt really
sorry for was these divorcee woman's
right because they were just coming out
of a very very hard time and single
mothers right because you know their
husband had left him and they got three
children to feed now they're working 12
hours a shift right and they're looking
for a way to get out of this rat race
you know the 95 cycle or in there is
much more and eventually they they
borrow money you know this was just what
I really worried me because I can have
to borrow money you know I had you know
such level of saving these would have to
borrow money and these people were
paying or not in one go like me one on a
monthly basis and now they are
complaining to me right in our group
that once we are having a coffee after a
meeting with Eric oh right that you know
I don't know how you know I'm gonna pay
my rent and this was going out of my
account every month and now you know
much more than the rented the bills and
utilities right I'm gonna have to find a
money to pay this month if not I'm
kicked out of the group so the one of
the leading rent or money from a parents
promising the seen pay back because
she's gonna make a lot of money cause he
has a platform on the stage now we don't
pay back and the you know her parents
moved us in the parent died and she said
I could never forgive myself
yeah yeah you want to sound like a guru
you don't sound like a guru when your
name's Eric exactly thanks master Aaron
I'm sound like a guru when your name is
Mosco dude any stupid little blanket
thing drives me nuts
I'm changing my name my disciples the
guess was straight
Shree give me money
welcome to Fager today we have sunny
who's giving us a testimonial on Eriko
which is pretty exciting cuz we just
talked about him and I think it
resonated with a lot of people a lot of
people said oh my gosh this guy's really
you know this is ridiculous is one of
the more ridiculous gurus we've talked
about so thanks for coming on the show
tell us a little bit why you decided to
come on and what you want to get done
here Thank You Steve I really appreciate
it I think it was about time that
someone should talk about Erica because
obviously I had gone through an
experience of losing my hard-earned
money with this guy and I wrong with me
there are a lot of people in the group
it's all right so everyone willing to
talk about it publicly but you know we
are all kind of worried off you know
anything legal cases lawsuits etc and
also depending on the people's
background right some people don't want
to reveal and you know everything
because you know a lot of people
actually who were in my group where
attending the events the courses you
know hope to make money so that they
could feed their family but you know
unfortunately I've lost it so as a
result I think you know there was a lot
of frustration and I thought you know at
times someone to provide it yeah
absolutely thank you so much for coming
on the culture of silence and shame is
definitely real it's definitely
unfortunate for the audience
sunny has chosen to be anonymous due to
his some job restrictions stuff like
that so that's the reason that's going
on right now I just wanted to make that
transparent for our audience
he has receipts of going through Eric
hoes course so this is a verified
purchase or hear verified customer so
let's just get into it I mean give me
the timeline when did this all start how
did you find Eric oh what got you to buy
in actually it's really funny because
you know at the time I believe he was
quite new on the Internet as well I
think it was one of these social media
platform where a small you know this ad
targeted ad appeared and I must have
clicked on it I can't really remember
exact time you know was the time
actually this was around three to four
years ago but I can't remember the exact
time when I kicked on and started
listening to some of his videos right
then obviously this was in London there
was a sign up for a free event on one of
these weekends so I thought okay why not
you know it's free or you know if I
don't attend or whatever it is you go
there right and it was it was really
good it was so carefully designed and
crafted to make everyone feel good and
there was a lot of a very I would say a
very high level of sales tactics
designed for people to purchase what
they were upselling hence it was free
right so I went there and I didn't buy
it straight away because I I was a
limited I wanted to be careful cuz you
know the money I had saved was very hard
on money and just going back slightly
about what he said earlier was thought
yes I am you know I have all the
receipts of the bank statement etcetera
to verify it I've been through its
course and you know so so I'm a legit
student or mentee right as they call it
and yes so that's how I came across it
and on the second time around when I
went I thought okay maybe this is a this
is worth my time and you know taking up
his mentorship right taken of the
program and and then you know you start
making friends with other people in the
break time you have coffee together you
start chatting and they're all you know
talking about signing up and then you
kind of make friends and you know you
have a coffee afterwards as well or a
drink and then you said oh can you sign
up right because we all want to get out
of this nine-to-five corporate job or
other people wants to get out of their
financial difficulties right so that's
that's how it happened and we signed up
and and then just to remind you sorry
just you you sign up because they make
it very very exclusive you know there's
only three spots left and this is you
know 50% discount today and you know
from tomorrow is going to go up to
fifteen fifty thousand dollars and and
and and then they bring some of the
geysers or the students who are
currently on the program to speak up and
then they come and speak to you on a
break time or the lunch time and
they say how wonderful it is but what
they don't know is they are also being
bring us at that time because you know
they are made to feel good about it but
surely there was some kind of commission
based I suppose you know there's some
kind of reward and incentive for them
that if we as a group sign up you know
say say we are a group of five and if
three of them sign up then you get this
wasn't a sex occur so they encourage you
to sign absorb the right all right that
the students encourage you to like hey
you should sign up you should sign up
you should sign exactly and you know how
good their life has been etc etc but on
in hindsight right now if I had asked a
question about you know not how good you
are feeling right now but how much money
you have made right from the time you
joined till now I'm sure do and we hope
to answer it because I'm learning that a
quite high - absolutely so you realize
these things afterwards and you know at
the time you just thought okay you're
gonna be one of those and yeah that's
how I signed up and so so to take you
back so you sign up for one year program
right and they promise you between 20 to
30 minutes appointment every couple of
weeks whenever every coach in London
right and he comes to London to give
these free seminars almost every month
because he wants to sign up more and
more people right so what happens is you
you come to a free seminar right and you
use massive high level sales crafted
techniques and then eventually say from
from 100 if you sign up - right or just
let's assume 1 right from from thousand
they can get 10 so if you are charging
between 10,000 or 15,000 pounds to 20 or
25,000 pounds depending on the duration
right then you can just multiply that
sub massive you know money they make and
eventually becomes a numbers game so now
they want to just keep doing this free
event and just deploy these very high
levels sales tactics like this
exclusivity only three spots left exit 4
etc and eventually they want to close as
many number as possible and that's and
then this guys were are employed on
their behalf saying
the program is accepted surely they get
some kind of incentive or the mission
and that really you know helps you to
make that decision because you know
that's a real life testimonial right but
what you don't realize is they are being
groomed they are being they are part of
the scam or or they don't even realize
it you know that's how good these guys
are not smart these guys are that they
are also actually helping yeah I'd be
really interested to know if they were
affiliate linked for example that's
really common where a student is
affiliate linked to the person and when
they they'll put like who signed this
person up and they put their name and
then if you do that then you get credit
and you may get like a kickback or money
from that sale because you're the person
who like basically Sonam on it that's
really common yes yes it's a good
question because now I remember because
when you are when you learned that
similar right you have to fill in this
form right and I remember reading this
part afterwards of course someone made a
comment on this as well they asked you a
lot of questions especially a business
idea what you want to do but one of the
most question is how much you earn how
much is your salary and how much you
have in your savings right and who is
talking to you who's looking after your
group so you could be person a right
hence now I think the next sense when he
said that you know they are getting
commissioned because that person a is
looking after my group and person B's
another group right so that was the only
question there and very funnily
afterwards all the people that has a
very good salary and a good job right or
savings gets selected and interviewed
right and interview is just really funny
because you go to this room and then
they ask you again what you want to do
and how motivated you are why do you
want it you know it's like I don't know
they are trying to make you make it hard
for you I suppose right and then you
know that's great and there's a synergy
here and and and then the way it's sold
during the program remember this program
is for about two to three days on a
weekend right so everything is carefully
done they don't sell it straight on the
first day they you know they give you
the motivation enough on the first day
on at the end they start dropping some
you know bits and pieces here like we
are looking for joint venture
partnership we're looking to work with
other people we can invest in their
business ideas if we like it if you
qualify for it because you only have
this many spots then you can give away
right right so on the on the day to you
are you're thinking I wish I could be
that person right and everyone else is
saying that is only in the coffee break
or if he chooses me you know it could be
my joint venture partner you could
invest in my business and you could
really sell together right whatever
you're selling could be product services
right and you get this and then towards
the end of it you fill that form right
and then you go through this interview
process but what we don't realize is
that's making everyone it's not yeah
exactly there was about fifteen of us in
the group at the end and each of you
were paying how much how much did you
pay for this course used the discounted
price at the time was twelve thousand
pounds right and then it could be
increased to twenty or twenty-five
thousand pound depending on you know
what expertise you need so for example
if you have a business right it could be
just providing a consultancy with this
therapy where they saw I don't know
advice etc right that means you could
end up you could just pay twelve
thousand pounds because which is our
honor of fifteen thousand dollars right
because your business already you
already have clients and you've already
done it but if you are looking to build
something brand new but I'd say I want
to build I don't know depend right on
and create a new pen and smooth and then
you want to sell it right so now you
have to you need more advice you need
consultants you need more guidance you
need more mentorship right and as this
is what you end up paying lot more so I
end up paying a lot more twenty thousand
pounds which is I love funny twenty five
twenty six twenty eight US dollars
twenty thousand US dollars and I'm
assuming that straight out of savings
yes because because if you pay straight
up you get discount that's why it was
around twenty thousand right but if you
pay monthly
then you know you end up being around 15
20 percent more now what what if what
had Eric Howe done at this point that
made you think this is the kind of guy
that's worth 20,000 good question he
talked a lot about two of his business
one was this noodle franchise chain that
he had and had googled extensively and I
went to one or two of them to have my
lunch as well just you know make sure
that they do exist and then there was
this apparently this steel and tire
recycling business and he talked of
elaborate Leon that business you know
it's business partner with this old man
and how you into China and and and you
know he had set up the whole meeting and
they didn't turn up and and there was
this guy you know on the phone and
suddenly called him up and then realize
you know it was him so there was a lot
of this thing about this steel and tire
recycling business and again I looked
into it he he had there was a company
existing with his name plus other people
as well so what I believe was that he
was part of this company but what I
didn't realize at the time was both of
these companies a lot of these companies
actually and when I said a lot cuz in
the UK you can literally hook on a
company you know within a day you know
register online and pay about $25 and
you can open it you can you can
personally right now open 10 companies
right now and you'll get a cookie know
three days later right in the company's
house so you have done that and a lot of
these companies were liquidated or
insolvent because they were unable to
pay the debt right which I didn't
realize and and everyone thought ok this
guy has you know been there and done it
all the stories successes absolutely and
then you know he these again you know
these guys are very good because they go
through this rollercoaster of emotions
they tell you know the shared story for
the hardship and that you know what he
did to overcome some of the hardship
right and then all this beautiful kinda
spiritual stuff you know this ethical
things is done and then like I said it's
why but two three days seminar and then
he goes through all of these
rollercoaster rides and
you think okay if you are going to join
bench of someone like him it's you know
it's a shooter Kyle it's a shortcut and
it's much faster because you don't want
to make all the mistakes along the way
right if you know that yeah right and
exactly and and and then the worst thing
for me right towards the end of this
mentorship when I started becoming
really upset because I was realizing
within 1/3 I was the first one to
complain in the group and you know
started telling other people was we met
right say say say so so you say I came
to an appointment or exist in London is
giving three days seminar and you get an
appointment on the on the fourth day
right yeah so he's there now finishing
is three days of seminar super tired cuz
you know this seminar goes on forever
oh great because they want to
deliberately make you tired they want to
deliberately not finish on time they
want to because it's easier to
manipulate you when you are very tired
and when you're you know just been
sitting on the room for a whole day and
you know doing high fives and you know
yeah say yeah yeah say yeah exactly
and they make you repeat this stuff and
and like I said there are a lot of
rhetorical questions about saying yes to
everything and eventually you know
you're not thinking much and then that
high level tactics of sales comes in and
then you know really bitter so so
another point I'm trying to make is that
so you get a 20 to 30 minute slot right
and when you go there he's trying to
meet about 15 20 people plus he's
meeting new recruits because remember
this is a new seminar now and then the
new leads and new students right so when
you go there you're you know literally
sitting behind a queue and you recognize
some faces because they are part of a
group or the other group and then
finally when your turn comes up the guy
is already looking at who is waiting on
the queue right yeah he's tired and it's
not interesting and then when he
mentioned remember we talked about this
last time I've done this I've done this
right
so would you go from here and he says
how about this and I said yeah you told
me that last time how about this yeah we
talked about that two times you know
a previous appointment how about that
and what have you done I said I remember
talking about this and he goes oh yeah
yes yes yes that's when you know the guy
has no track record of you know where
you are and he's not interested because
he's already made the money and he's
only interested on the new recruits
because that's who's gonna pay the money
Brian that's when we realized you are
shafted that's when I started voicing my
opinion to the you know the group I was
in 10 15 of us and they were
unfortunately you know these were nurses
plumbers divorcees single mothers and
they were just telling me you're so
negative son you know Sonny why are you
so negative you know stop being negative
you gotta be positive you gotta think
about the law of attraction you gotta
read books on that like he said you got
to manifest things and it's gonna come
to you right and in the beginning I was
polite but afterwards I was very you
know even I was kind of giving them
heart when I saw that look I'm a
practical guy you know I work on defense
projects and you know you know if things
don't things doesn't just appear
magically that's that's sort of a toxic
mentality that you always have to be
positive because as soon as you're not
positive and you realize this isn't
going how it was promised to me
well now you're of course it's not
working for you because you're being
negative negative yes absolutely and
it's no different than any you know on
any of this you know this big network
marketing business where you know a lot
of people are running around trying to
recruit more people right because they
are in this pyramid scheme right and
people know that you know they are not
allowed to talk negative they are not
allowed to you know be asked any
questions about the founders right the
top level management guys right but you
know if you look at companies like I
think their phone line is ACN so this
biggest multi-level marketing companies
right only if you look at the terms and
condition I think only 1% makes the
actual money they're promised less than
1% it's less than 1%
it's about 0.3%
yes yes and not yes absolutely and these
guys are using that tactics right and
what I felt really sorry for was these
divorcee woman's right because they were
just coming out of a very very hard time
and single mothers right cause you know
their husband had left them and they got
three children to feed now they're
working 12 hours just shift right and
they're looking for a way to get out of
this rat race you know the 95 cycle or
in there is much more and eventually
they they borrow money you know this is
what I really worried me because I can
have to borrow money you know I had you
know such level of saving these people
had to borrow money and these people who
were paying or not in one go like me but
on a monthly basis and now they are
complaining to me right in our droop
that once we are having a coffee after
meeting with Eric oh right that you know
I don't know how you know I'm gonna pay
my rent and this watch is going out on
my account
every month and now you know much more
than the rent the bills and utilities
right I'm gonna have to find a money to
pay this month if not I'm kicked out of
the group and and I said ready and then
and then this one guy who works for them
he's like you know one of these debt
collectors big massive Spanish guy I
think his name was he was a debt
collector for for for Eric and he's his
company and and and it basically calls
you and then you know gives him the
warning you know we taking you to court
I think they have an in-house lawyer
because I never had to face this
remember I paid in one go but these guys
were called several times to remind him
to make the payment they were not kicked
out straightaway obviously they are
given a bit of a chance right the money
right exactly so there was a lawsuit
threats they were you know these guys
calling them all the time suggesting you
need to make a payment no matter what
and if they say they don't have the
money to borrow and this good these
women right they were borrowing from
their parents and the friends and I feel
really sorry for them and one of them
was crying all the time because you know
because she she couldn't pay the money
back or see thoughts you'll make
money by work of course with every Anna
fasted exactly manifested and then and
then and these women right some of them
were given some of them were given
opportunity to share the stage with him
so you know with all credit to him right
so they got on say 20 minutes slot right
on the stage say they would come to the
stage and they could talk about how good
you know it has been to work with Erik
oh right and then what they do for
living like a therapy consultants right
and how they help people etc so they
could sign up these followers you know
who were attending this free seminar
right and all themselves were not making
money any money at all well they were
making money from you know their own
clients right so say they were providing
a therapy for a client right so they
were making that but they wanted to
increase that so so anything that has
they sign up through Eric right he gets
a commission on that 50 percent split
wait wait one second Sonny I haven't
heard this part yet
oh no no you're breaking new ground
without me let me catch up yeah okay
say that slowly so say this one of these
men teenage students right guess 15
minutes time on the stage with Eric so
Eric speaks and you know talks about
setting is you know all this
motivational stuff right and then and
then he says okay now I'm going to
introduce you to one of my students my
mentee you know who's extremely one of
the world's best professional coach blah
blah blah blah and then he or she gets
the time stays for 15 minutes and then
they eventually have to sell right
because that's what they are a I'm
joined that's what they're paying Eric
for right so if they sign up say 10
people on their therapy session for one
hour each etcetera so they charge $100
but Eric gets 50% of that so eventually
eventually all the people that you see
in his website I'm a creator or
something right you should all these
people with the testimonials all the
people continue coming to the states
they have paid
about $20,000 or $15,000 to share the
stage every you know in one of these
seminars to upsell their their product
or service you know you've been selling
I think that 50% of it there - - airing
and then they were getting frustrated
some of them because they had to do all
the work right because once you sign up
a client then you have to do the work of
the client and 30% and what really
pissed me off was that right this lady
who had board money right from their
parents and the friends to pay money she
had to chase his you know secretary one
of his team member to the money went to
Eric actually write the money because
because they had signed up from Eric's
seminar and they had also signed up from
something called webinar as you know
webinar right so eric has these safe ten
thousand followers he calls everyone and
then this cell right now the money when
they book it goes through its website so
now they had to call their team to ask
for the fifty percent and they had to
call them a lot of times because they
were not getting paid on time right and
one guy another therapist he did use a
coach right he just gave up he said
after three months I give up you know I
don't want to work with this guy I'm not
gonna say another one yeah exactly you
know I don't want this 50% you know I
didn't know and he left and and he left
and there was another girl who left
suddenly so I was you know in touch with
her so I contacted her and I met for the
coffee and she said she couldn't pay and
you know this is this debt collector
kind of guy said basically in that case
you're out right so we have a whatsapp
group where everyone is chatting right
she was kicked out and she was blocked
because Eric does not talk to people who
can't pay because he has to be this
merciful guru right you know who might
have to accept her so he she's blocked
and I wish she wants nothing to do with
it and eventually when the program comes
to an end right the whole group is
closed saying you know the program is
over all the best and then everyone is
just kicked out and all you see is you
know this is kicked out
and suddenly you see a name you're
kicked out and that's it and you have no
contact with him whatsoever and and and
then and then so few of us get together
and say [ __ ] what happened you know
right and then that's when you started
realizing the horror stories because
some of the one of the lady who had
borrowed money from a parent's promising
the scene would pay back because she's
gonna make a lot of money Rossi has a
platform on the stage now couldn't pay
back and the parent you know her parents
who the Scylla parent died and she said
I could never forgive myself
boring our money and not paying back on
time because you know that I can never
you know I can't rewind that time isn't
it right and she was crying literally
and I remembering one of this event
because you see when here part of this
mentorship group he he has all these
events ongoing right and you're invited
free again so then he's now upselling
driven courses he's selling public
speaking courses right for a weekend for
5,000 pounds for $7000 for weekend for
two days all right and that he's selling
unscripted Kenya cause you had this
charity thing in Africa right right and
I know this is another the scam which
I'll tell you about right because he
actually raises money in the seminar
right and in various other point when
you're meeting or when you're going for
dinner etc and then he he says he gives
it to the the charity in Kenya yeah but
we don't actually see it right so now
he's of sending the public speaking
course he's up selling another forex
trading course without one of his you
know right and then he's up selling or
trip or charity tripping in Kenya and
you know how much that cost for about a
week
tell me I can't do with the exact figure
but it was no less than five thousand
pounds no less than seven thousand US
dollars okay right and you get the
t-shirt you gonna do a charity work and
you take pictures with this beautiful
children right okay that's a good cause
but you're paying extremely high amount
of money yeah approach if you're going
yourself okay let me be honest what
bothers me the most about Erica
and just it kind of offends me is not I
mean I've just seen a lot of gurus and
so I'm a bit numb to it at this point
but what I'm not numb to yet is these
people going under the guise of like I'm
your spiritual leader and I'm like I'm
gonna lead you know I'm gonna lead you
to fulfilment and happiness and it's
just kind of your way and he put puts
himself as this like he calls himself
the master now right I have the answers
by the do you know that he calls himself
like a thousand years old or something
like that like he's like no idea
no no what he said when you go into the
Himalayas you meet people that are
thousands of years old and recently I
went on a Himalayan trip and I was
hiking that mountain and I met some
people and they were thousands of years
old and then he talks about when he went
up to the Himalayas to go get his name
changed he was up there for like a week
or so but then he says that the time
wasn't real and that he was actually up
there for I think it was like years like
he's like actually I wasn't away for 30
days this what I was talking about on
the cc+ yeah I know I was away for years
because it was in different dimension
yeah and and only the more conscious
people will understand that yeah so so
he's this wise old man really - ready to
teach you all the all the lessons of
life this I mean that just bothers me
and tying that into uh because typically
I mean you know there's now all sorts of
people who do these kind of things but
typically spirituality is like
disconnected from money like give me
your mind you know materialism right
give me your money give me exactly but
he's actually you know it's a different
twist in his game isn't it right he's
using that to target vulnerable people
because if you were targeting or
corporate worker right working for
footsie 100 company in the UK or say
fortune 500 companies all this big giant
you know tech companies in the US these
guys are more you know I'm not trying to
be rude here but you know you know they
have been in the corporate game it's
dog-eat-dog world competing for yeah
exactly promotions and etc so they are
much harder to sell but
when you come when you're targeting
vulnerable people you divorcees are
plumbers you know who's going out of
business right you know you know people
who's sick of nine-to-five you know just
an adversary and they want to get out
and do something in their life right
they're much susceptible vulnerable to
to accept this this this this I would
say this this platform that is providing
right and how easy it is to make money
manifestation and and he's doing that
and now he's as you know right he's
showing off his material wealth all over
the internet and connecting that with
with with the spiritual stuff which is
completely wrong but unfortunately it
becomes a numbers game because you know
when you have millions of views millions
of people following you eventually you
don't have to sell 5 percent 3 percent
or 2 percent and you know you made a lot
of money and I'll tell you why this
works you know I'm realizing this now
have you seen a program in a Netflix
called wild wild country right now about
this Indian guru right I mean people are
talking about it a lot now actually so
what this Indian guru called Sri know
yeah yeah 3 run somewhere Richenda
Rajneesh
Shree Rajneesh right he had he had
millions of followers okay right the guy
had
he was the biggest collector of
rolls-royce in the world I think he had
about 96 rolls-royce right and and he
came to move to the United States from
India with all his followers mainly 90%
of a Western alright okay and and yet
and and then he bought all this stuff
and then he made his own country they
were all wearing just a red robe simple
lifestyle okay meditation all kind of
activities right and they were growing
their own food you know farming etc and
and you know why he had so much money he
was worth I think 100 million at the end
right you know why he was worth so much
money
well as all the people that that joined
his country in the middle of USA so
we're in Oregon right give up the house
given all the savings being brainwashed
and he had a freaking black account
Department you know signing all the
contracts and Louis and everything and
they were Hollywood stars by the way
they were doctors hi no yeah right
bring me you're rich exactly and these
people 7,000 or something like that if I
remember the program right live there
and they were creating all sorts of
trouble to the local the country with
the public people you know all kind of
mess and all console you know trying to
poison the water to the for the local
people etc etc and you know the police
you know they had guns they had their
own armed force I mean if you watched
wild wild country you'd be shocked you
know how these people know I definitely
will that's fascinating
I'm the ground to Jet's by the way the
guy had two jets and at the end where
the police were trying to catch him you
know what he did he left everyone behind
and I ran with with all the diamonds and
all the girls and everything dad did
they caught him before he got out of the
continue you know luckily and he had to
go through the whole course you know geo
and then and then he agreed a deal with
the government the United States
government to go back to India and sing
and those people now has nothing to go
back to who gave up their house their
savings
yep that's that's the thing that
frustrates me is that people I think in
desperate situations they go for people
like Eric Oh because they think things
can't get worse
I'm already in a bad situation what
could make this worse I'm just going to
debt I'll just push it all bad at all
and the reality is that things could get
much much much much worse and people
finally people find that out they go
what could be worse than working my
nine-to-five job well working your
nine-to-five job $20,000 in debt or
$25,000 in debt or $28,000 whatever it
is yeah that's yeah that's super
predatory it's hard to get this across
now why doesn't the UK government do
something because this is very hard you
know you see you don't know buying
anything tangible right you're not
buying a product and say you know I
bought this and then you know it didn't
work right so it's not like that it's a
consultant service right and it can you
can argue both ways and what eventually
happens is if you take a matter like
this to the court what eventually
happens is that you know you've signed
up and you can show you the receipt and
and then on the back it says yes but
there was an offer for you know to
cancel the program and ask for your
refund within 7 days you didn't what the
hell are you gonna snow in seven days
you don't know you know yeah you're
buying a co-driver game you don't know
anything
exactly and then and then and then the
by you know didn't have a voice and
everything you know very good lawyers
who could argue that you were given this
you know this strategic advice and right
this kind of consultant business secrets
or best practices you know the entities
all sorts of word right and you didn't
implement it etc channel so it's very
hard to argue this case not only in the
UK but also in the USA hence you know
this gurus makes a lot of money and and
and then you know I I strongly believe
he changed his name right to Sri this
whatever this thing is calling himself
now yeah because he knows that's how
these guys are Shree Rajneesh and then
there's another one Sai Baba
right in India here fifty million
followers in the world right and
and then when he died check this out
when he died when he died the police
raided his house and they found over a
hundred kilo goals I think 300 kilos of
silver you know jewelry and ornaments
right and and he thought I was worth I
think five to ten billion dollars
something like that some some argue sir
up to thirty million dollars and he was
the spiritual guru and he called himself
the incarnation of God and and then and
then and then you know that he was
actually able to do some tricks so these
you know tricks to I don't know you know
you know what the magician does right
they do something oh I've heard this guy
he's exactly he's supposed to like
manifest a watch in his hand and like a
surly fight of him he goes like this and
he actually done it and then people
believed it oh but I wasn't sure when he
showed it in his slow motion there was a
freaking it was all a hand trick you
know what the magician do right he
learned all the best of the tricks and
he actually does did that so back in the
days all right 15 million followers dude
in the world and the guy was was between
five to thirty million dollars billion
sorry five mm that's so unfortunate they
actually they found you know underground
in his probability proper private
property but the police raided it with
an army right because you know obviously
his followers wants to fight right so
obviously that will the army so so they
found over honey killer of gold or 300
kilo of silver and I don't know watches
and jewelry and all this you know this
design of perfumes and I mean so so the
reason Eric Howe is changing his name
from Eric how to master sri blah blah
something right right it's because he's
literally following their lead because
that's the easiest way to make money
yeah yeah you don't want to sound like a
guru you don't sound like a girl when
your name's Eric it's a trick thanks
master Eric sound like a guru when your
name is master oh dude any stupid little
blanket thing drives me nuts that he
likes shrouds himself in a blanket I
that pisses me off
oh this dude like he's now he like wraps
himself
now to be all spiritual exactly and this
is literally following these girls
that's what they did you know simple
life material no materials right and on
one second I gotta go grab something oh
my god you made my day
hello my child I am a sir master give me
your money
Shri give me money it's absurd it's
crazy beginning on the background right
yeah yogi in the Lamborghini it always
talks about did I solve anything the
other day where he's like yeah if Buddha
were alive he'd be a businessman it's
like no you don't understand anything
honestly this guy's taking the piss he's
taking to the next level because you
know he's putting words and things that
you know you shouldn't cuz you can't
really put your opinion publicly out
there on you know people's religion
right I think she'd have respect for
world religions and if that's a
different matter so what I'm probably
say is that he's following all this
Guru's path because he knows it worked
and he made it work you know these guys
made millions billions in that case
right so you know he's looking for a way
to become the you know will quickest way
to generate millions and that's why he's
changing his name that's why he's
getting into more into spirituality and
all this manifestation Law of Attraction
because he knows there's a massive
audience out there massive followers
know our vulnerables yeah let me ask you
something let me ask joke so I got a
message from somebody on Instagram he
goes did you know he makes everyone
stand when he enters the room and only
address him as master did you have any
experience with that or did that is that
the new Eric that's the new Eric
remember I was with on that program
right several years ago
and so Dustin here Eric and he lives in
Lincoln share Lincoln in England right
and he invites people there you know
he's gonna garden and a house and then
you know makes all sorts of parties from
barbecue to all this meditation stuff
now you know so literally I wouldn't
surprise if he's doing that in his house
right and and you know this this it
works because he's that's the target now
you know that's where he makes the most
money that's where people are vulnerable
and that's easier you know and if you
notice one thing this law there are more
women audience right in this law of
attraction and manifests and stuff then
then then then then men and they're more
I would say you know a lot of Asian as
well why do this stuff cuz he knows he
needs a lot of the philosophy origin is
from Asia right yeah or you know every
part of the world but it's just this
massive audience there and and then and
that's why he's doing it and then the
other thing I want to talk about quickly
was that during this you know this
program that you're in right he's
traveling all all over the world like in
you know in America in Vietnam in Kenya
the charity right again it seems like a
charity but what he's doing is charging
people like you know 5,000 pounds on a
one-week you know to to Kenya and he's
actually making profit out of it okay
alright so and so basically imagine you
are in London or you are in the u.s.
right you signed a write him
you can't even meet this guy the guy is
not even in the country you know happy
chorus LMS and he doesn't respond and
then you know and here you're fed up you
know you're stuck you're trying to you
know get some solution right because
you're this business person right who's
trying to create a product or a service
and it's so difficult and finally you
you get our appointment with him okay
he's gonna have a seminar in this
location right that back weekend so
after the weekend is going to stay one
more day in in that location so he can
have a meeting with you guys right and
you get a half an hour try me a slot and
like I said when you go there you know
there's three people in front of you and
they're by the time you sit and talk to
him this for five people waiting for you
to finish you know that's crazy
that's so you paid $20,000 just sit
around
way basically yeah and then literally he
talks about things he doesn't know
they're all he provided I mean what else
did he provide that could be justified
under $20,000 nothing and there's one
more thing you know there is you know
Anthony Robbins right you know his son
is I think from Jarek Robbins right and
he works with Erika and they do this
package deals I know you're gonna be
shocked guys there's so much of it
these package deals to go to South
Africa I think it changes every year
so say let's go to South Africa or let's
go to Indonesia Bali let's put the body
right and we're gonna spend a week
together in a 5-step I know one of these
luxurious apartment a hotel right and
then who got a party in the evening in
the night right and then in the daytime
we're gonna go you know we're gonna
meditate we're gonna do fire walk and
we're gonna discuss business ventures
like all the things happening in the
world and and and then you have to pay
ten thousand pounds which is fifty
twelve thirteen thousand pounds dollars
used on us for that for one week holiday
and he was upsetting so much on that so
I said so I said right okkkk because I
think because you realize you know I had
quite a bit of savings where I just fail
up front I don't know I wasn't paying
monthly
so I said okay okay let's get this
straight what are you going to actually
discuss who is this guy okay I know his
father is the world famous okay I give
credit to that okay Tony Robbins okay
you know he's up there okay alright but
what has it got you know I haven't even
heard the guy's name you know just
before he told me has is he has he got
an MBA or as he worked for one of the 14
five-minute companies had you got any
real-life
corporate experience a business
experience is no so he's just another
guy who just talks like you and and and
and what is the actual value I'm going
to get and you know what he said I said
it's very hard to define that it all
depends on you so it depends on how you
take it right because you see we could
be in a jacuzzi relaxing and we could be
talking about a small business venture
and something could just click
and manifest right and that that that
that idea could be worth million dollars
right oh we could be I don't know just
drinking and you know chilling with all
the students and we're talking about
spiritual Eric is okay you don't really
house
it's a spiritual value sunny you
wouldn't understand this is this is
something that only seafoods and masters
and people like me and Eric understand
okay and that could be worth millions
and millions of dollars it's really
priceless honestly it's priceless so it
shocks me that you would even ask
millions upon millions of dollars and
you're lucky were even giving you any
time at all you need a manifest harder
is the sense I'm getting us these poor
divorcees they didn't go to something
you didn't manifest hard enough the
plumber didn't manifest hard enough none
y'all manifested hard enough you know
what you know what that restaurant owner
should have done she should have started
her own course company I think that's
how she could have manifested of course
that's what I always think to myself is
like if you want to make as much money
as these gurus say they're making just
run a course it's insane how much these
people are making I've slept in throw
your ethics out the window but um yes
yes and you know the funny things start
getting a record start getting his
mother involved is all right so she
start coming on sitting here you know
normally have a second idea of the stage
and all the seats right on the back they
have something to sell like the books
and the CDs or are you on a sign up you
have to go and you know write your name
there and put the credit card details
there so I remember he was sitting in
one of these seminars again a free
invitation because you are part of the
group right so I was just kind of
scratching my head at the time like you
know why am I even here because I know
what he's going to talk about I know
he's gonna try and upsell right what why
the hell am I here you know and it's
because you know to be honest with you I
wasn't mad I was a Manning up you know
right I win there because I felt guilty
if I didn't go because the guy has been
talking about if King you know all the
time right and then you meet his mother
we at the back of the states along with
all the people
who are in a rage to take your critical
details with the terminals to put your
PIN number and and then he comes there
and then he you know obviously upsells
he's one of his program and then he says
you know fifty percent off or 95 percent
off I'm only looking for two spots right
so when I say three you know that the
first two gets goes there and gets it
you know
the others are conduit right and then
and that is really amazing because he
counts three and then you look back this
is some freaking mayhem you know it's
like it's like the whole building is on
fire
everyone is trying to sign up and
pushing each other literally literally
and and you sit there teas and and then
he talks about something for a couple of
hours right which is one of his story
and then now he's telling another
program and again the same mantra the
same procedure and then literally you
know just cells absolutely I mean I have
to give it to him you know he can sell
but this is unethical selling right and
what's really a you know for me was that
he's getting his mother involved and and
you know you know there was a post
during that time if there was a post but
how he gave his father
I think thirty five thousand dollars
Rolex watch right and he was putting out
on my Instagram and the Facebook on a
youtube about it you know how Happy's
father is how proud his father's etc and
I want you to go and do the same thing
right to all his followers but well and
then you know when he's a traveling to
say the US right he's pushing his
picture on a business flight you know
business class flight right or first
class and but what people don't realize
or at least I was really upset in my
heart that you know I'm fitting funding
is yeah you're finding that like
everyone who's like watching is saying
like wow this is an amazing lifestyle
you're finding the life's not funding
that and then in the what's really drove
me mad like you remember I was the black
sheep right you're made a mess is caring
exactly and and the people in my group
right these girls were remember I said
nurses single mothers Wow you know will
be
that some day I'm like don't you realize
our money you know and then then I go
you're being so negative
like look I've gotta stop going to this
kind of group chats in the future
because I'm telling you what's real
what's practical right what's happening
and you guys are just telling me that
I'm being negative and yeah I am I'm in
the wrong group right so and then and
then and then yeah so he was doing the
same thing about his mother
you know like giving her a gift about
some cars and etc and and and then
obviously his mother was sharing that
post his brother and his sisters you
know they are his brothers also they're
actually right so he's also part of the
group and you know his team right so so
eventually his sister they're all
sharing these feeds and eventually their
friends are also joining this you know
coming to these seminars because they
all want to know you know who these guys
and you know yourself you know my sis my
friend's brother or my sister's friend
right so they're all coming along and
eventually like I said it's a numbers
game so you sign one on our twelve
thousand pounds from every one hundred
right so you know you want ten you just
get thousand people to your ten year
seminar yeah and it's just so hard and
and you get and and then you keep up
selling them throughout the whole year
right it's the upsells that really get
people it's because they like they lose
money and then like well I'm already in
it with Eric oh and he's telling you
about all these other great programs
that are gonna you know manifest you and
you're just not manifesting right now
and it'd be too negative try again
and that's that's how they get you and
then what was really bad is when they
encourage you to take long when they
encourage you to ask
that's horrible it does that happen in
Eric's program that's what happened to
this lady who got kicked out I didn't
know they were encouraged encouraging it
though they encourage that kind of thing
the the Bulldog that I mentioned about
the debt collector right basically this
girl was struggling to pay and she was
asking me for money and I said you well
as a friend you know like you think I
can borrow right I say well I was
borrowing from anybody she literally and
you know I got to just you know the
message and I didn't talk about it right
because then I think she got the point
and and then you know so I was just you
know
more of a you know a friend who is
trying to encourage there you know that
you know hey you know you know like I
was just talking about things like you
know don't get into this dance and you
know I've been very negative from the
start
right and you guys have pulled me off as
a friend right but you see now it's
coming kind of true because the guys we
can't even get in touch with the guy is
where is he now he's in South Africa is
in Bali in her in years
right so she was obviously dealing with
this this debt collector guy who was
obviously who didn't kick her out
straight away because you know if they
do that then obviously didn't get any
money right so he was threatening her
with a legal lawsuit and then he was
telling her that do you have credit
cards and things and she said yes of
course right can he ask him to increase
the limit and I think she was saying do
they do that yeah yeah if you actually
do they will right and if they do
actually if you actually cool the
currency can increase it and she was
doing that and surely she made some
payments you know maybe two three months
worth of him through that and when she
couldn't do that anymore right and which
couldn't get the loans credit limits
anymore
she was out like I said out of the group
Eric doesn't have time to manifest you
let's start wrapping this up do you have
any kind of closing thoughts or anything
you're thinking of that you didn't get
to that you'd like to say about I mean I
think everyone really appreciates having
you on telling your story obviously it's
not easy to do it's painful as you said
anything you could thank you thank you
for the opportunity right I'm going to
pass the the the pain point now you know
it's been several years plus I've been
involved in many other adventures right
because this is what I wanted to do and
you know obviously try it as much as
possible to learn from it so that it
doesn't happen right so it takes me a
lot of effort to try and listen to a
guru you know I mean I don't listen to
it [ __ ] unless they you know there
are someone like Bill Gates or Steve
Jobs exit right alright somebody in the
pocket like that right so you listen to
people like that that and if people are
really interested in business all I can
say right is to never ever ever go to
these girls
right now they only talked about one
thing which is they talk about shortcut
mode where this manifestation or whether
it's a or I should say they can the
mindset whatever it's all [ __ ]
yes you do need mindset but you need
action more than anything else
99% is grit sweat hard work sleepless
nights seven days a week
you gotta you have to sacrifice social
life you can't make up you can you know
meet your friends when they only
birthday celebrations right you're gonna
come back with the red face when they
say no when I finally said no to you and
then you go you know check the two hours
journey back home right and then next we
could overcome that and be excited and
go back and pitch to another one it's a
hard work out there man and no one talks
about this is giris because they won't
talk about our dream the nine-to-five
escape and laptop you know exactly and
then the manifestation thing is that you
dream about it and then it's gonna
happen to you now skipping that the main
important part the hard work the effort
the time right right it's very likely
that it's gonna be over the budget no
matter what estimate you made and it's
very likely there's no written as twice
as long to make it happen so that's my
experience so honestly only if you need
motivation listen to those guys who has
been the Eternity no real executives
real business man's you know which is
branch should right we put them above it
Steve Jobs
you know Elon Musk right cuz these guys
really have been through it and they
never ever talk about all these things
that these gurus talk about this woo
manifestation stuff the secret and all
that crap so that's my that's that's my
parting phone you know that's my
suggestion I think that's really great
advice and I think it cuts against what
a lot of people want to hear a lot of
people want to hear the shortcut even
though all the Guru's will tell you it's
not a get-rich-quick scheme it usually
actually is in fact if you have to say
it's not a get-rich-quick scheme it's
probably a get-rich-quick scheme real
companies don't have to ever tell you
it's not a get-rich-quick scheme they
just like you just know they're just
legitimate and if someone has to say oh
this is gonna get rich quick scheme it's
probably a get-rich-quick scheme so yeah
I appreciate just a little bit of real
world advice obvious
since you've since gone on and done very
well for yourself so thank you sunny for
coming on the show and yeah I hope your
story inspires others and informs others
so they don't make the same mistake
absolutely yes yes I just hope they
don't have to go through this whole
emotional turmoil you know that's the
most important thing I think cuz money
you can always make it right if you do
well within a short time of space you
can make a lot of money it all depends
on you know what kind of what you're
doing right but emotion and the time
that you waste with people like these
takes a lot of time too well you time
you can't get back right money sorry
emotion you know you need you need to
build yourself up and you know that
takes time to actually overcome as well
so it's just a really you know really
bad thing these guys are doing because
it's that money you paid to these guys
right you actually really need that
money for a really suitable business cuz
when you're setting your business you
need every single penny like I said you
know your focus your budget your
estimate will always go over that so
that means you're now having to put
money together from all sources and then
you realize oh my god and I not spend
that much money to this bloody stupid
guru right this fraud right I would have
actually used that money now and I would
have you know made this thing happen
so those regrets will really hit you
back and it's really painful because you
made that mistake right you made that
decision and for a lot of people in my
group they couldn't tell their parents
they couldn't tell their partners
because they made this decision secretly
that's why they couldn't come to the you
know to the webinar to talk like this
from the camera right because they are
living through it and it's you know it's
very painful thing wow thank you so much
thank you thank you everybody for
watching have a good one thank you very
much cheers thank you
[Music]
[Music]
Sakura
[Music]